[Music]
i believe he drowned in colville bay
and that's what captured my attention
when i saw your station's report
a son's attention captured when he saw
these photos skeletal remains in the
sand at lake mead last month the eight
news now i-team broke the news about a
body found in a barrel and a week later
kayakers found a second set of remains
the man that you just heard from
believes the bones could be his father
only on 8 news now here is the i-team's
david charns after he drowned
i was told that he went away
todd kolod only knows the stories others
have told him about his dad daniel he
went out regularly and he ran out of
people to give fish to todd was just
three when his father drowned in lake
mead it was june 1958 he was on a speed
boat with a friend when they hit a wake
and they got flipped out of the boat the
boat ended up about a mile away in the
next bay over but several witnesses told
the national park service that they saw
kolod drown here in cauville bay this is
what's left of it today crews searched
the bay here and the other side of the
lake but they found nothing kayakers
finding skeletal remains in cabo bay
this may not far from where danny colad
succumbed to the lake's waters those
waters receding hundreds of yards since
then when i saw calvo bay my eyes
bulged wide open
relics from the good times in the lake's
past now visible on its newly exposed
shore
todd kolod watching from his home
overseas thinking
this could be his dad is there something
just telling you like
i really think it's him i'm just lining
up the clues part of those clues involve
his father's dental history danny kolod
was in a car accident a few years before
he drowned he lost his front teeth in
the crash and wore a partial denture
what sticks out to you in this photo as
a dentist well there's only four teeth
in particular we brought the photos and
kolad's story to dr debra staton she's
certified in helping identify remains
based on dental records what can you
learn from someone's teeth
well there's a lot i mean
teeth are
a signature basically just like your
fingerprints staton says it's clear the
person here is missing their front teeth
i feel like those front ones were
freshly removed she also says the person
likely was missing other teeth before
their death bone and teeth are solid
which is why they become
this gold standard for identification
because they don't change i mean if it
just sat there undisturbed that's
probably how it arrived there but just
based on the photos she can't go any
further the key to solving who the bones
belong to finding daniel kolod's dental
records there was no dna testing in 1958
getting a sample from todd now the only
way to potentially solve this mystery my
grandfather
he did everything he could to find the
body
i know we did and so i just assumed it
was an impossibility for todd kolod what
was once impossible could now be
possible with time this could be my dad
or
my dad could be the next discovery
64 years later in the middle of a severe
drought lake mead revealing her deadly
secrets along lake mead i'm david charns
live local now